i just want to start by saying
it is always a pleasure to talk to you
i'm a huge fan
i think it's amazing that i get to do
this you know get to talk to you like
this
oh please my pleasure thank you uh i am
curious
i always like asking a few questions
that are not about the movie to start
things off um
when did you feel like you made it as an
actor
that you could do this for a living and
like pay rent doing it
well i'll tell you it was 1975
i did an audition for a lady who's no
longer with us called mary o'malley who
ran built and ran this theater called
the lyric
players theater in belfast and it was
during the height of the
troubles and i auditioned
in order to become a professional actor
and
after my audition i don't think i was
terribly good but i think she saw some
kind of passion
there she sat me down i just
she and i in the auditorium of the lyric
theater
and the more she talked to me about how
hard it is
to be a professional actor the more she
she
she uh said how hard it is to get work
70
or out of work all the time i kept
thinking to myself
she's going to offer me a season
she's going to offer me a part in this
next play
and she did and uh what got me the part
was the fact that i was six foot four
and they needed somebody over six feet
to play this particular character
but anyway i signed a contract uh
in october 1975
to join this theater for a season which
was then doing a play
every four weeks uh the whole european
american calendar
shakespeare arthur miller
you name it and
it was then i i absolutely loved it i
just loved it i loved it i said this is
what i want to do
for the rest of my life you know never
dreaming of film
that was something way way way out there
somewhere
uh the height of my dreams would have
been
to be in the national theater of great
britain maybe the royal shakespeare
company
and that was it but uh doing those plays
every four weeks that was
uh that was the greatest high
i've ever felt i'm glad this worked out
me too so one of the things about ice
road
is that uh when you guys made it it was
an indie movie and then it had this big
sale to netflix
when you were making it um did you have
any idea it was gonna
i guess talk about landing on netflix
and the whole world gets to watch it in
like a week
next flicks bought it and they paid a
lot of money for it
which is great they're a huge streaming
service as we all know
and they do some extraordinary programs
and programming
um but we had made it for a bigger
screen
i just have to say that you know it
wasn't made
specifically for netflix netflix bought
it and
there we go and it releases on june 25th
i believe one of the things about the
film is that i believe you did that
sequence where you go in the water
and like the freezing cold water you
actually went in
on what take did you actually say this
was a really bad idea
no i never did i i i knew it was coming
up
i'd read it in the script i thought okay
they asked me what i want my stunt
double
mark van slow that we've done 25 movies
together
to do it i says no i i want to do this i
i practice a little bit of the wim hof
method i don't know if you know
who wimphoff is this is a guy who
you know climbs halfway out everest up
climbs halfway up everest and a pair of
shorts
and hiking boots and bare chested
and he has these breathing techniques
and he submerges himself in ice cold
water
both my sons practice it i practice
it a little bit and so i knew
i wanted to do it and uh and we did it
we did
maybe three takes certainly no more than
that
and then we had a wonderful hot tub
about 100 meters away off the ice
where we could just get the costume and
all
and thaw out for 20 minutes or half an
hour
uh when i when i spoke to you for the
marksman earlier this year
i mentioned that disney was doing the
star wars series with ewan mcgregor
and i think i was i think i might have
told you this for the first time i don't
i don't know
are you a little surprised at how many
people have been bringing up star wars
with you
um and did you ever get that call from
disney
uh i heard you i'm just doing this
series and i um
uh it's called obi-wan right or ruby one
kenobi
um i haven't been approached
to be honest um i know there's so many
spin-offs my i
i'm a little confused i must admit
but uh and you know when i was in the
first one the phantom menace it was like
oh
would you sign this it's uh it's for my
kid
and now it's like oh would you sign this
it's for my father
or would you sign this it's for my
grandfather i mean it's been
just you know three generations now
since these
movies came out and i remember being in
belfast in the theater
uh having a day off and going to see it
uh the first one i think it was episode
four i believe
with harrison and mark and carrie of
course
and uh in this packed belfast
cinema all ages kids
old people packed and hearing sirens
outside army trucks going by because it
was it was a bad time in northern
ireland let's face it
and uh and seeing this extraordinary
film uh set in outer space
sat in different planets and stuff and
uh it was just totally unique and
incredibly entertaining
never once did i think i might be a part
of it somewhere down the line but
it's still going strong and as i say
that
all these spin-offs and i'm not
surprised uh
there's a spin-off of obi-wan and
newman's there
i look forward to seeing it very much i
really hope you make a guest appearance
i have to go
listen thank you so much for your time
congrats on everything i hope everything
goes well with you
thank you thanks buddy